[Music]
there is a story about a Muslim a Jew
and a Christian all sitting together at
a dinner table it's true it happened it
happens and should happen more often
where we can talk respectfully
peacefully and share each other's views
now they came to the topic of religion
and the Jew says I only follow Moses and
his companions interesting the Christian
respondent says well I accept Moses but
follow only Jesus Christ and his way oh
very interesting very interesting now
the Muslim responds and says well my
Jewish friend this is not being said to
appease you but as Muslims we love
respect and believe in Moses as a
messenger who was sent by God and did
you know that he is mentioned with great
honor
136 times in the Quran into the
Christian he says did you know that
Jesus is also mentioned 25 times in the
Quran with great honor and respect and
that we love him as another mighty
messenger of God because God Almighty
says in the Quran say o believers we
have believed in God and what has been
revealed to us and what has been
revealed to Abraham and Ishmael and
Isaac and Jacob and The Descendants and
what was given to Moses and Jesus and
what was given to the prophets from
their Lord we make no distinction
between any of them and we are Muslims
in submission that's what a Muslim is
one who submits their will to the
Almighty to him it's in the Quran
chapter 2 136
so as Muslims we don't stop at Moses or
Jesus but we accept them both as
messengers sent by God whom both called
people to only worship the creator and
not his creation and whom both foretold
of another messenger to come the final
seal of the prophets Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon them all
so we accept them and we also accept him
my sincere advice is for you to look
into this great man's life because he
was indeed a messenger who was sent with
a message for you - thank you very much
I hope you enjoyed don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and do your best to
help us reach our goal more info in the
description below assalamu alaikum peace
be with you
Oh